I want to show you what Joe Rogan had to
say in response to seeing this video I
think he was on on a show with Matt
taibi good
[Laughter]
do that again what the is this is
that have you ever seen anything that
looks more like where's the fat people
tell me that doesn't look like feds
right it's like the 101st Airborne
Runners these guys look at they just got
out of buds I mean what the out of
here
what the so uh so I saw someone
comment you know it's not real because
whenever you see an actual right-wing
militia group they're all morbidly obese
or at least a handful of them are not
all of them and it's like that that's
actually fairly interesting now I have
seen people push back and say don't
underestimate them they like that
they're being called feds the actual the
reality is someone posted an image from
an internal FBI report where the FBI
actually warns that among the FBI half
of the agents are morbidly obese